it's jennifer's avasanja bloomber quick
take thanks as always
for being here with us today so as you
probably have noticed
natural disasters have been wreaking
havoc across the u.s for several weeks
and the devastation has now made its way
into the u.s
election with president trump and
democratic nominee biden
disagreeing on what exactly the science
is telling us
and so we wanted to ask an actual
scientist
what he is seeing based on his research
which is why i asked ucla climate
scientist daniel swain to be here with
me today daniel how are you
i'm doing all right thanks for having me
yeah well thank you so much for being
here i know this is a really busy time
for you so i appreciate you making some
time for us
um so i just wanted to start off first i
mean
it seems like year after year the fire
season is getting worse and worse
can you first like walk us through how
did we get here to this point that we're
at right now
well essentially you're correct that the
data do show that in california
over the past few decades fire seasons
have become progressively worse both in
terms
of the the number of acres burned and
the number of very large fires and the
the harm that those fires are causing to
humans and to the environment so that
much
is certainly the case how we got here
where we are right now this year in 2020
with
really just an astonishingly severe fire
season both in california
and now also in oregon as well
there's a few different time scales that
i sort of think about when i when i go
back
in time and think about how we got to
where we are now one of which
most immediately we've seen some
record-breaking heat so over labor day
weekend some parts of california saw
their highest temperatures in recorded
history during
any month back in august
for those who might recall california
saw another record-breaking heat wave
and that one was even more sustained
lasting many consecutive days so there
have been two
instances of record heat recently in
california that have really
dried out the vegetation in the short
run
uh in mid-august there was also a big
lightning event
in coastal california what's known as
dry lightning
so you get the thunderstorms with the
lightning and the wind but no rain
reaching the ground so that ignited a
lot of the fire some of which are still
burning
today and we look back even farther to
the
recent winter that we had in california
which was exceptionally dry
in the northern part of the state so
that also helps at the stage
so we have recent record warmth a dry
winter preceding it
and then of course in the long run we
have the long-term warming trend so we
have climate change and the influence
that that's having
in the long run drying out the
vegetation and making it easier
setting the stage for these extreme fire
weather conditions to occur
when we get a heat wave or a wind event
or a thunderstorm
and it's still really very early on in
the fire season correct
yeah california unlike much of the rest
of the west actually has a fire season
that extends well into autumn sometimes
straight through
october or even november especially
recently as our fire seasons here have
lengthened
and that's because california for the
most part doesn't really receive
any meaningful precipitation during
summer so the vegetation becomes
progressively drier as you go through
june july and august and peaks and
dryness actually in september
or october before the winter rainy
season arrives
and it also so happens that the autumn
is the time of year when we
along the west coast tend to get what
are known as offshore winds so these
a very dry land to see east to west
winds that can sometimes be quite
violent this is unfortunately what we
saw up in oregon last week
where the winds were gusting as high as
60 or 70 miles an hour
and the vegetation was bone dry at the
same time so you can imagine once you
get a spark under those conditions
uh those fires are just going to spread
pretty uncontrollably and of course
since that season peaks in the autumn in
california
uh we we are not we are just beginning
the autumn
uh as of mid-september right now so we
still have at least a couple more months
of peak fire season in california to get
through and are those wins that you're
talking about is that the santa ana and
the diablo wins or is it different
what's happening
yeah so those are two regional examples
of the kinds of offshore winds that i'm
talking about the santa ana winds in
southern california the diablo winds
closer to the san francisco bay area
they have other names on a more local
basis going north all the way up into
the pacific northwest but they're all
they all
share this similar characteristic they
tend to occur most often
in autumn are often associated with very
dry
atmospheric conditions and if they occur
before there has been substantial
rainfall
during the season which is currently the
case throughout the west coast
and will likely to continue to be the
case at least in california
all the way through october or even
november they are strongly
uh historically associated with major uh
fire activity as well
and we heard i mean present you're in
california and
president trump was there on two on
monday it's tuesday today
um and president trump has in the past
blamed the worsening conditions on
flawed management uh of the forest i
wonder i
you've done research on this you have
data on this what does
your research tell you about why things
are getting so
worse over the next over the past few
years
well since i'm a climate scientist our
research specifically takes a look at
what the climate or atmospheric
component
to extreme fire conditions is in
california and elsewhere and what we
found essentially
is that the global warming that's
already occurred
has already doubled the occurrence of
extreme fire weather conditions in
california like we're seeing
right now in the autumn so there is
already a pretty strong human
fingerprint on the
increasing propensity for fires to
become very large and burn
very intensely that doesn't necessarily
tell us anything about how the fire
started but it tells us what happens
once these fires begin given a spark
what happens next and the evidence
clearly shows
that climate change is increasing the
size and severity of fires in california
and in the west
more broadly now there are other factors
that are important
and there is a kernel of truth that the
historical legacy
of total fire suppression policies in
the forests in the american west
have by themselves increased the current
fire risk in places that have
uh dense forests today because we
excluded
the beneficial on the natural low to
medium intensity fires for
so long that a lot of these forests have
grown
and become somewhat unhealthy with
vegetation that is more dense than it
would naturally be presenting
more opportunities for the fuel to burn
but acting on top of that still is
climate
change even in places where there is
this legacy of this total fire
suppression policy
and interestingly of course the fire
suppression policy in forest is only
relevant
in and near forests and many of the
fires that are currently burning
are not true forest fires they're
burning in other types of vegetation
brush grass and oak woodlands things
like that and there
the larger influence really would be
things like climate change
and increasing urban incursion into high
risk zones so in other
words another factor is that
increasingly many people live
in harm's way in these high fibrous
zones so it's really these confluence of
three factors
the increasing propensity for people to
live in harm's way
in some places the legacy of total fire
suppression policies in the forest
during the 20th century
but even more pervasively and on top of
that and something that's relevant
essentially across the landscape
is the growing effect of climate change
which is making fires more intense
yeah and is that um the wildlife urban
interface is that what you
call when people are moving into these
um spaces that were not
typically inhabited by people by humans
right so in the
in the um in the business the wildland
urban interface refers to
sort of places uh where there are
a substantial number of homes and
businesses
where there is also a substantial amount
of potentially combustible vegetation
and so this sort of describes the
overlap
between where wildfires can occur and
where there are substantial human
settlements and of course
that overlap has increased a lot over
decades and there are a lot of studies
pointing to the fact that
one of the reasons why we're seeing so
many more homes burned and so many more
lives lost is partly because
there are more homes and lives at stake
because people live in these regions
because so it's
sometimes it's you know it's often said
that it's you know the the reason why
things are so bad the reason why we have
this escalating wildfire crisis
it is because of urban development or it
is because
of forest management or it is singularly
because of climate change whereas the
reality
really is that they're there all of
these things are important to various
degrees in various places
and we can't really just look at one in
isolation and say
that's that's the singular cause it
really is all of these things
unfortunately
acting in concert to make the problem
worse so
most of the solutions then are are
unfortunately
not a silver bullet kind of answer
either there's there's a range
of of ways that we need to be tackling
the problem
because there is no single cause
so then what are you i mean you're
paying very close attention to what's
happening
on the west coast right now what are
your models telling you about
what's at stake over the next few weeks
how are the winds moving
how is this going to affect people uh in
the coming weeks
well you know the challenge is that
we've already um you know reached this
extreme state of things along the west
coast
as you mentioned earlier well california
still has at least a couple months
of peak fire season to go so many of
these fires are going to burn until
significant rain or mountain snow
arrives later this year and in the
pacific northwest so talking about
oregon and washington that could happen
sooner rather than later so the rains do
often arrive some point even as early as
september or certainly by october in
that part of the country
the challenge is i think going to be
greater in california where the rainy
season
even historically typically wouldn't
arrive until late october or november
and recently has been arriving even
later than that so we've been getting
quite dry conditions even into november
so we may yet have uh the rest of
september certainly october
and then maybe even november again where
these fires could may continue to burn
and that is of course the time of year
when we start to see these offshore
winds so offshore wind season has just
begun we got an early event
uh around labor day which helped push
some of these fires
uh but that's early for these sorts of
events and so typically the historical
climatology is such that they occur with
greater intensity and frequency as we
head through the autumn peaking
late autumn or even early winter so we
still have a couple months to go in
california
and unfortunately i think some of the
fires that are currently burning
especially the ones in more remote areas
are likely to burn straight until the
winter rains arrive so many of these
will continue to burn for weeks or
months
and could be exacerbated if at any point
during that period which is
unfortunately pretty likely there is a
significant offshore wind event that
pushes these fires
uh very strongly in a new direction so
the good news in the very short term is
that i think some of the smoke that
that has been choking a lot of the west
coast cities is just starting to clear
out
the pacific northwest may get some rain
this week actually so up by seattle and
portland
um that will help with the with the
northernmost fires
especially the ones in the cascades no
real rain is expected for california so
there's less of a benefit there but at
least in california too
there will be a wind shift that helps
clear some of this choking smoke away so
at least
it'll be easier to go outside and open
the windows for a lot of people in the
urban parts of the west coast who have
been sort of stuck indoors
due to air quality issues even though i
think the the broader problem
of these fires continuing to burn is
going to last a while still
yeah i've been reading about just how
toxic
it has been for people that they can't
even go outside and even seeing some of
the images that
we have i mean this orange sky that we
saw last week was shocking to a lot of
people i wonder if someone who's looking
into these models often were these
images surprising
to you and is the severity of this
current season
a surprise to you in any way well the
severity of the current season is
certainly
it's shocking even to those of us who
study this but i
i unfortunately i don't think it's
particularly surprising from a
scientific
perspective so it's horrifying to see
and yet it's
very much consistent with predictions
from fire scientists and ecologists
and climate scientists that we've made
for years because
you know those three factors that i
mentioned the the increasing
expansion of the wildland urban
interface the legacy of
fire suppression policies in the 20th
century plus climate change on top of
all that
all these things have been pushing the
risks in a bad direction making the
problem
much worse there really haven't been
many mitigating factors
they're all amplifying the accelerating
the problem so
really folks from all these different
disciplines have been making
similar uh warnings about what was
coming next
and unfortunately we're seeing a lot of
those predictions borne out in
really dramatic and tragic ways this
year
with the escalating wildfire crisis
on the ground right now so it's you know
it's
um it's honestly kind of sobering to see
and i really hope this serves as a
wake-up call that there are a lot of
things that we need to be addressing
urgently um and there's a lot of things
we probably need to be thinking about in
a different way when it comes to
wildfire we already knew that climate
change was
a real and growing problem but i think
um it's events like these i think that
make it
more visible certainly more visceral for
i think individual people because it
really is profoundly affecting millions
of lives right now in the western us due
to these fires
yeah and when we talk about individual
people um you know we have some people
watching
today what can people do on an everyday
basis to break this current cycle that
we're on how would you advise someone
who is
you know not able to go outside or even
people who are watching and looking at
these images and want to
stop this or do something to contribute
to hopefully this turning around
well i mean i think it's it's it's it's
challenging because it is difficult i
think as an individual to to
to really get a grasp of the enormity of
what's going on and the kinds of
solutions that might
uh really help deeply address the
problem and really there are a couple
there are several different distinct
problems i think one is the wildfire
problem which is itself sort of composed
of these three different elements that i
that i keep mentioning
um some of which are more tractable than
others obviously from a climate
perspective
um you know the the the good news is
that we
we can still choose to to eventually
stop global warming by bringing our
collective carbon emissions down to
around
net zero um currently we're not still on
that path so
having conversations with your friends
and families and neighbors about
uh the the importance of getting there
and what it means to you
to be experiencing these climate related
disasters that we're seeing right now i
think is really important
getting out there and pressing uh policy
makers
and you know allowing these sorts of
issues to influence who you vote for
there there's a big election coming up
that i think really is an important part
of this because it is difficult for
individual actions by themselves to
scale up to the kind of solution
the really enormous large-scale
solutions that we need to solve this
problem
but one step in the right direction is
having those conversations and really
pressing
uh folks to to to have these
conversations as well
on the wildfire front there are some
things that may actually be a bit more
tractable i think
in the short term and on the individual
level
in in that there there's a lot of
evidence that how
we build our homes and where we build
our homes can very much influence
their likelihood of surviving a wildfire
being exposed to one in the first place
so there are
there's a lot of evidence out there that
the building materials that we use and
the kind of defensible space that you
have around your home for example can
greatly affect
outcomes when it comes to wildfire how
we design our communities at the at the
individual community level even can
affect
how vulnerable they actually are to
fires in the first place
or what happens to them if a fire does
eventually come along
but i think the most interesting aspect
of all of this is
there is a bit of a paradigm shift i
think occurring right now
in the fire community um and how it's
sort of promoting
uh to the general to the broader public
this notion that
that wildfires are not inherently bad um
the kinds of fires we're seeing right
now are bad
i don't think anybody would would
disagree that the fires that kill people
and destroy homes are bad
um and that burn for us at very high
intensity that may
make it impossible for those forests to
regrow as they once were that all those
things are not good those are not the
kinds of fires
that anybody wants to see but on the
other hand um
you know fire at a lower to moderate
intensity that is that is
burning um not near populated areas or
not
actually directly affecting um
structures and
threatening lives may actually play a
really powerful
role in in solving the problem
this notion that that managed fire or
prescribed fire can actually help
is one of the most effective ways on a
large scale of reducing fire risk
it's one of the reasons why the problem
is so bad right now because we excluded
all of those low to moderate intensity
fires in the forest over the 20th
century
and it's also potentially one of the
solutions in a warming climate because
there is so much risk right now that
there is only so much you can do
to protect communities when these
extremely intense
climate amplified fires burned through
an area so one
possible solution there is to embrace
the notion of
more good fire more of this low
intensity fire on the landscape
as an alternative to the continually
suppressing
the larger and more intense fires
maximally and then sort of losing
control anyway
when the weather conditions become too
extreme so a lot of folks have realized
that
more fire on the landscape in a warming
climate in the 21st century
is essentially inevitable but these
destructive mega fires
are not inevitable we we can choose what
kind of fire we want to have
on the landscape and i think if we
choose wisely we may be able to avoid
some of these
fire catastrophes that we're seeing um
in so many places right now yeah i think
as you mentioned it's not there's no
silver bullet solution there's a lot of
things that we can be doing
right yeah that's right and i think it's
i think even even
you know in terms of of ways to advance
the the narrative the dialogue and move
towards solutions i think even
talking about the problem in that way
which is to say that it is complex and
that it has
not just one single cause but many um
interrelated causes and that yes climate
change is part of the problem but also
yes
the legacy of fire suppression is also
part of the problem and yes the
expansion of the
the wildlife urban interface is also a
problem
so addressing all of these in concert in
a more comprehensive way
um certainly not easy um and it's not
cheap but
like climate change more broadly you
know
the solution isn't cheap but the the
costs of doing nothing
are arguably dramatically higher than
than the expensive solution so you
in order to do an honest cost benefit
analysis you also have to look at the
cost
of not intervening and i think it's
becoming clear that the costs of not
intervening
um in a wildfire sense
are similar to the cost of not
intervening more broadly with climate
change which is to say
it's all going to be a lot cheaper and a
lot less miserable for a lot of people
in the long run
if we deal with this up front
proactively rather than trying to
respond to and recover from these ever
increasing disasters
yeah i think i mean i'm i learned a lot
from you daniel and i
i know we want to be mindful of your
time so um
i think we'll leave it there but i
really appreciate your time today and
hope that you can come back
um hopefully we don't see any any
worsening devastation but
hopefully we can have you back on here
in the next few weeks
i would love that thanks daniel thank
you again
all right